an international backlash is growing
against india after islamic comments by
a ruling bjp party official during a
televised debate
the saudi-based organization of islamic
cooperation has condemned the remarks
saying they came in a context of
intensifying hatred towards muslims in
india
new delhi has responded saying the
comments made by the oic are
narrow-minded
iran's foreign ministry has summoned the
indian ambassador to tehran to express
its displeasure
and pakistan has released a statement
criticizing the derogatory remarks it
said pakistan once again calls on the
international community to take
immediate cognizance of the grievously
aggravating situation of islamophobia in
india
qatar's foreign ministry also expressed
its disappointment doha has called for a
public apology from the indian
government
well a number of shops in kuwait are
removing indian products from their
shelves the senior bjp officials
islamophobic remarks has prompted calls
for a boycott of indian goods in the
gulf nation
in a statement the bjp said that it
strongly denounces insults of any
religious personalities of any religion
adding that the bharatiya janata party
is strongly against any ideology which
insults or demeans any sect or religion
let's go live that in new delhi al
jazeera's pagni mithal is there these
comments have obviously angered many
people
how widespread is anti-muslim sentiment
there in india
you know so right now the bjp and the
indian government are trying to do
damage control they're trying to put out
statements and reaffirm their belief
that you know all religions are equal
that they respect all religions and
they've called these opinions
opinions of
fringe elements but uh critics in india
point out that the actions are too
little too late first of all the two
leaders in question that the government
has now suspended well suspended one and
expelled the other
held very important roles within the
party one was a national spokeswoman the
other was a top leader in the media
division for the party in the national
capital over here and so critics point
out that um
you know these these fringe uh opinions
that the party is claiming have actually
become mainstream in um in india and
that goes back to a history of its top
leaders making inflammatory comments
anti-islamic comments
anti-minority comments openly and
getting away with it uh pretty easily in
fact a few months ago there were leaders
that called for genocide and violence
against muslims in public meetings and
rights groups that have pointed this out
in reports have
been met with a lot of resistance in
fact they've seen their offices either
shutter or
their foreign funding frozen in india so
now there are opposition parties that
are asking the government to apologize
and take responsibility for creating an
environment in which comments like these
have pretty much become common all right
so these comments have caused a problem
for india internationally what about
internally politically how much of a
problem is this likely to be for prime
minister modi and the bjp
so these comments have put india in an
very embarrassing position that has put
uh you know it's strained diplomatic
ties and also um you know sort of
threatening economic ties because there
are growing calls for boycott for indian
meat products now just so you know these
are countries particularly in the gulf
region that india has spent a lot of
time and effort building close ties with
trade is worth billions of dollars over
here domestically there has been
violence
on friday after friday press protesting
the bjp and these comments violence
broke out in the northern city of kanpur
dozens of people have been injured cases
have been filed against hundreds of
people security was also beefed up
over the weekend
apart from that there is growing
criticism about the environment that the
bjp has created that the mainstreaming
of a communal discourse in india and
that is what opposition parties are now
pointing out they're also attributing
these actions to the international uh
backlash and not necessarily a sort of
soul-searching and an ideological
commitment to religious equality and
freedom in india al-jazeera's pavli
matal reporting live from new delhi
pavilion thanks indeed uh let's speak to
former indian diplomat vivek katyu who
joins us now live from gurugram in india
good to have you with us uh sir what do
you make of of this this row how does
india get out of this mess can it get
out of this mess
well uh
i will distinguish between
religion and politics
i think there is an abiding belief in
india which is rooted in our
constitution
and in our tradition
that all religions must be respected
and that there should be no blasphemous
comment about any religious leader
and certainly i for one uh
was shocked
uh when i heard these comments on the
holy prophet because that's not in
keeping with what i've grown up with and
what all indians have grown up with to
believe that that no religious
personality no no faith should be
denounced so uh that is one aspect and i
do think that the bjp has taken action
uh by expelling one of the one of the
person one of the members who made this
comment and by suspending its national
spokesperson
the other is a political confession that
is underway in india
partly ideological partly purely
politics
so
i for one would draw a distinction
between these two and i can appreciate
that
there has been
an outrage in some sections of islamic
opinion abroad perhaps all sections that
hearing these comments
and
but i also feel that it has to be placed
in the perspective of the action that
the bjp has taken and more importantly
in the tradition
of religious respect
that india has pursued all through
the years and decades of its
independence okay all right and i don't
see that that respect is going down all
right but nonetheless this this does
threaten to to damage india's reputation
among
its gulf allies in in particular you
could argue that the both countries need
each other
economically
however it it it does threaten to to
damage india's reputation and
the money that it that it gets from uh
trade with with gulf states
what does it need to do now to restore
its reputation qatar for instance is
asking for a public apology from the
government will it get it
well
i think there is a mutuality of interest
between india and the government
clearly there's a mutuality of economic
interests there's a mutuality of
security interests
between india and the gulf countries and
that
interest
is shown in growing in the growing
relationship between india and the gulf
states
i don't see that that is going to go
away
because of this incident
also i think that both both the india
and the gulf states need to see this in
a perspective and contain the fallout as
far as india is concerned
this was these were comments made by the
ruling parties folk
people
in one case a spokesperson another
member and the ruling party has taken
action
the indian embassies
who were
demarched have also issued statements at
this stage
i haven't seen any statement from the
government and perhaps since this is an
evolving situation at some stage uh
some kind of a dialogue may take place
between the government and the country's
concern
but
what i would like to under underline is
the mutuality of interest
between the india and
the gulf region
good to talk to you sir many thanks
indeed for being with us vivek can't you
there including
thank